it's another beautiful day in Sydney I'm
out enjoying the Sun and looking to find
out if anyone knows why the Sun shines
so the Sun gives us a lot of hate
sunshine the divides energy yeah he
doesn't like really where does the Sun
get that energy from I no idea I have no
idea some kind of chemical reaction
yeah gas explosions doesn't it burn gas
the burning of gases it's burning up for
the fire that's on the Sun
but is the Sun really a giant ball of
fire I mean wouldn't it go out after
five billion years one of those things
that you just assume you know but then
you don't actually know
so in this bucket I have the components
of the Sun well I have protons and
neutrons there are some electrons but I
didn't bring them okay
most the Sun is actually protons okay
and so what are the protons doing the
Sun it dance together okay
okay when they come close you know what
they do they just flat well actually
they bounce off each other I'm coming in
oh why did the protons bounce off each
other sometimes with electrons
how's new native oh yeah cuz it don't
like each other they don't like each
other that's because a proton needs a
neutron right you know why they they
repel like that
magnetic force the repelling magnet type
thing Megan silver electric field
positive and negative positive and
negative it's to do with the positive
negative right we got protons protons
are the positively charged yes the
positive you're probably good okay this
is why it's so important that the sun's
hot because if the Sun is hot enough it
gets these things moving so fast that
sometimes they can't avoid a collision
okay when they get too close they
actually go
smash the brothers yeah yeah yeah no no
dispatch oh and now they're stuck
together and you saw what happened when
they smashed together what happened they
leaked is that synergy yeah see well the
water pulled out but I guess energy
would have poured out it the energy in
the channel the energy came out what was
the energy before it was energy kinetic
thought energy so what's happening there
it's releasing some mass yeah yeah
waiting and that mass is is kinetic
energy
it was the mass of the proton proton
smashed together they got lighter
yeah and they lost that mass and the
mass was converted to energy you know
famous equation about that it's good
it's good yeah e equals MC squared
forget ends to do have you heard that
famous equation which person person
makes energy Wow equals MC squared
yes so what see the Sun matters energy
emi's mass see Cassidy carbon I don't
remember
what's he means sir C is the speed of
light speed of light no right Billy
yeah huh isn't that weird the speed of
light right huh well now why do we have
sides it seems most people have a tough
time remembering that C is for the speed
of light maybe that's because C is a bit
of a strange letter to represent a speed
in fact an Einstein's original paper he
used the letter V for velocity of light
but nowadays everyone uses the letter C
for constant it's a constant of the
universe the speed of light though some
people claim the letter C stands for
celeritas the Latin word for swiftness
what is that equation telling us about
energy and mass
energy equals constant mass the mass and
the energy combined together creates the
energy he's basically saying like this
mass that comes out gets converted to a
lot of energy and the speed of light is
a huge number
yeah you think about that tiny bit of
mass is a huge amount of energy so every
second the Sun is actually losing 4.3
billion kilograms every second that
amount of mass is being converted into
energy in the Sun hydrogen fuses
together to form helium but that's a
little confusing because how out of only
protons do we create a helium nucleus
which has two protons and two neutrons
well the thing is when the first two
smashed together one of the protons
actually emits a positron and a neutrino
it quickly becomes a neutron next thing
that happens is another proton smashes
in and again we get more energy released
now if two particles like this collide
they emit two protons and what we're
left with is the helium four nucleus
there you have hydrogen fused into
helium and a lot of mass lost a lot of
energy released yes if you want to know
more about fusion in the Sun check out
this video by minutephysics it explains
how the protons confuse even though
they're not really going fast enough to
overcome their repulsion hot enough for
fusion will fuse together anyway and the
Sun is so big and has so much hydrogen
that these small chances happen all the
time